I would much rather be healthy and take
care of myself and my medications are
important and I believe and they are
what helps me Selena Gomez getting real
about her struggles with lupus I'm very
honest though in general the star goes
live on Instagram to explain how
medication for Her diagnosis affects her
body tend to hold a lot of water weight
and that happens very normally and then
when I'm off of it I tend to to kind of
lose weight she also takes a moment to
send a heartfelt reminder to fans I just
I just wanted to say and encourage
anyone out there who feels any sort of
Shame for exactly what they're going
through and nobody knows the real story
so
I just want people to know that you're
beautiful and you're wonderful but
doesn't hesitate calling out the haters
too thanks for supporting me and
understanding and if not
go away because honestly I I don't
believe in shaming people for
body or anything
million times
I'm not one to forget
you know
yeah sells no stranger to addressing
online Trolls but it's her commitment to
spreading kindness that's never wavered
with kindness
you're constantly somebody that likes to
grow and feel like all right what could
I be better at what could I do better at
where where could my confidence be
stronger and in her documentary my mind
and me the singer doesn't shy away from
sharing her challenges with lupus then
just when I thought it couldn't get any
worse
it did
my lupus you're in pain
they're gonna figure it out you're gonna
feel better it just hurts like in the
morning when I like wake up
immediately it started like crying
because it hurts like everything in a
weird way I feel like it is it's a time
capsule of a period of my life where I
look back and I actually feel bad for my
that version of myself and I I think
that it was good for me to see how I was
responding to my body the way I was
acting the way it was so irrational at
moments and I think it was really
healing for me to see that and get it
out I think so I never actually was
afraid to to tell people that I want to
take time for myself I never thought
that was a bad thing so to be sharing to
be sharing something honest and saying
hey I'm taking a break because I need it
I'm being honest and I think that's just
who I am
[Music]